where we at for real don't sugarcoat
this [ __ ] as of now how long is it
gonna last how long are we gonna be in
seclusion we will start to see plateaus
the end of this week probably and it's
gonna be Airy weak don't get me wrong
you know New York obviously we've had a
couple days now where it's been stable
which is awesome but I think the rest of
the country we're gonna see increases
and then we're gonna see plateaus and
then over the next several weeks we're
gonna start to see declines because
we're fighting back do you think that
there is a bunch of people in this
country right now frantically working on
either a cure or something to reduce the
symptoms are there initiatives going on
that we don't even know about no
question about it there's one campus
developing a vaccine but it's going to
take another 12 to 18 months to make
this vaccine there's another group of
people working on treatments and the
treatments are starting to show that
some of them may work and then they're
the people working on the testing and
this is the key testing is who's been
exposed who has immunity in the country
because their countries now they're
giving immunity certificates that means
if you had the virus you can go out and
you know go in public cuz you're not
gonna spread it and you're not going to
catch it anymore so you can go out so
actually using data for policy Beth and
I were afraid to go out yesterday and
I'll tell you why now we're hearing if
you are near somebody somehow in the air
that you can get the things so the virus
is spread by droplets when you breathe
if you stand in front of a mirror and
breathe those are droplets on the mirror
right it gets foggy if you wear a
bandana in front of the mirror and
breathe it doesn't get foggy because
that that a bandana blocks the droplets
when you go outside and go for a walk
somebody stops and talks to you their
droplets can spread it to you but
droplets are gravity so they'll hit the
ground so if somebody was there a minute
ago they're not gonna be droplets
floating around there so you have to
have a conversation with someone or
engaged with someone but this is the
reason we're saying everybody needs to
wear masks when they go out not to
protect you from getting the virus but
if you're asymptomatic
I don't want your droplets to spread to
somebody else if you really have to work
together when we see this country open
in May it's gonna be said everyone needs
to wear a mask when they go out so you
think the country is gonna get back up
on its feet in May that
people will start going out again that
like for example I would go into work
you know well I mean is that well not
Jim well you know what I am scared
shitless of this I don't want to go
through this I'm really afraid I think
it's gonna be a rough week and I think
it's a week that it's easy to get
depressed and it's easy to get
demoralized and it's easy to say listen
I'm doing all these aggressive things
maybe I'm just gonna go out but don't go
backwards everyone really we have to
keep it straight and then we're gonna
start to see a leveling off and we're
gonna see a decline and in May we're
gonna start to see a reducing other
restrictions we all have and our economy
is going to come back we're gonna go
back to doing what we were doing there's
nothing fundamental wrong with any of
our companies or our strategies we just
got hit by this horrible virus and we're
gonna come back in that regard and I
have faith in science I have facing the
men and medicines that are being
developed now I have faith that we will
have a vaccine and I have faith in all
of us that we're gonna do the right
thing to get to where we need to be I'm
an optimist
I really am